hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to ah yes
though we all just love Disney that
cuddly feeling a childhood innocence
mixed in with that special brand of
magic that only Mickey Mouse and friends
could provide t-shirt Disney is messed
up don't believe me then check out their
villains
these are some of the nastiest baddies
that ever shined on the silver screen
they were cruel wicked and oozing with
pure concentrated evil they did their
best to give you their worst and we're
here to honor them today for if it
wasn't for these Masters of darkness
does anyone have that edge that actually
does manage to bring some of the
Psychopaths back so I am counting down
the top 11 meanest demons that the
happiest place on earth has ever
produced why top 11 if you don't know by
now kiss it this is the top 11 Disney
animated film
the devil gypsies have to me
love it cuz I
karela deville from 101 Dalmatians
becoming something of an iconic role
Deville is the epitome of style meeting
psycho this nasty lady's plan all hinged
or outline to make fur coat out of cute
little cuddly puppies and the more evil
and psychotic she looked the more
adorable and multiple or hero's moon how
can she kill those cute little puppies
this is even worse than the time she
opened up that new line of baby seal
head necklaces I'm pretty sure I saw
Kanye West wearing one of those too but
surely once she sees how cute and
lovable those little puppies are she
wouldn't dare commit such a horrible
crime poison them drown them bashed him
in the head tiny Clervaux I don't how
you kill the little beasts but do it gee
lady gorilla was great for covering
herself in stylish attire but always
showing the True Blood hungry monster
that live underneath always yelling
always angry no he's fashionably insane
if fur is murder then karela Deville is
the h-bomb of the animal kingdom number
time Jafar from Aladdin it's said that
this villain was drawn by a woman who
happened to be pregnant at the time if
that's the case I think she needed a lot
more epidural Jafar was a mean-looking
customer with a long face sunken in eyes
and a slithering voice you late I really
love this guy's voice it's like if
Michael Crawford's testicles finally
dropped Oh
frightfully upsetting on top of that he
was a great sorcerer hypnotizing people
altering his appearance and even giving
his parrot the voice of Gilbert Godfrey
what a despicable notion okay take a 90
mark I think my favorite scene is when
he proposes to Jasmine to be his bride
you're speechless I see a fine quality
in a light gallon asshole he also takes
on a lot of different forms you see him
as a wizard you see him as an old man
you see him as a snake you see him as a
genie and even see at one point as a
straight guy
with his evil smile and devilish laugh
Jafar continues to be everybody's Rabia
nightmare
remember that scar from The Lion King I
know a lot of people like this villain
but I put in pretty low on the list
mostly because he's just a power-hungry
dictator that's not to say a lot of the
other villains weren't power-hungry
dictators but here's the thing what they
do get their power there's still
interesting characters when scar gets
his power he stops being interesting and
instead turns into a whining little
prima donna
you're just not looking hard enough it's
the lionesses job to do the hunting I am
a king I can do whatever I want now I
need to apply more mascara but for all
his faults guard didn't have a sense of
class and elegance to it Jeremy Irons
voice really knows how to capture that
slimy nature of the traditional villain
making everything he does seem
disgustingly evil plus he is one of the
few Disney villains that actually
manages to kill off one of the main
characters we're worried on that one
Jafar haha you'll get what's coming to
what's coming to me what do you know
what's coming to me idol alright that's
not cool
smart sinister and full of slime this
menacing feline put the hell in hello
kitty
number eight Scheer caught from the
jungle book knocked off this is a little
bit more what scar should have been like
a powerful bloodthirsty killer who's
still had a sense of honor and dignity
to him part of that is because he was
voiced by classic actor George Sanders
and nobody can show more class than a
guy who weighs a freezing student still
looks respectable even though the
character did little there was so much
build-up to him that you couldn't help
but be intimidated Shere Khan will
surely kill the boy Mowgli will meet
here calm the tiger
he hates man Oh we'll just explain to
him that I know one explains anything
shit huh you knew he was deadly and he
knew it too
he was afraid of nothing smiling and
nodding even when he knew he was being
lied to the best scenes involved his
talk with Cobb the snake he's another
great villain though I don't think he's
in the movie enough to really make the
countdown but good old Shere Khan is a
good filler maybe even the dumbest of
mancubs regret their bravery right
friend run run why should I run a little
idiot everyone runs from Shere Khan you
don't scare me I won't run from anyone
down there I'm going to close my eyes
and count them it makes the chase more
interesting one
two three
or you're trying my patience five six
seven eight nine ten now you did fast
deadly and always having very good
manners Shere Khan was at the top of
sophisticated evil number sir
rhadigan from the Great Mouse Detective
out of all the Disney villains this
one's probably the funniest I know a lot
of people like Hades or Captain Hook but
this guy is just so egotistical and so
diabolical that he takes the cheesecake
not only is he an evil genius but he
enjoys every single moment of it
giggling and laughing all the way again
a lot of what makes this character stand
out as the voice actor Vincent Price
knowing how to mix bloodshed and rage
with giddiness and joy he's so evil that
his picture actually smiles once you
mentioned his name and now that's a bad
what makes his character so great too is
that he tries to hide his inner raging
beef with all his class and
sophistication but by the end he's just
as psychotic as any other power-hungry
monster if you weren't afraid of rats
before this movie you certainly will be
after Radigan evil never looks so good
and bad at the same time
number six Ursula from The Little
Mermaid
this was a fun villain a massive
overweight sea witch who always had a
twisted look at her I like most villains
all she wanted was power but she looks
so delightfully crazy while trying to
obtain it on top of that she had a great
design with a half human half octopus
thing going on something I've never
understood those that she always
complained about how she looked and then
she had to live with it but look she
transforms herself into a beautiful
woman later she's so hot that even the
priest is getting a boner but oh well I
can't bring too much logic into a movie
where people can actually talk
underwater Ursula was a perfect menace
cunning deceitful and of course anyone
the best Disney villain songs ever
yeah choice
she's an eight-legged creature that most
likely won't be stepped on anytime soon
number five guests on from Beauty and
the Beast this is a very different kind
of Disney villain he doesn't start off
as the epitome of evil or even as a
villain he just starts off as a jerk
egocentric and totally self-absorbed
it's funny because he's the kind of
good-looking character you see save the
day and Snow White or Sleeping Beauty
which makes him a great contrast with
our real hero the Beast does he even
have a name of course as time goes on in
Gaston's greed and pride transforms him
into an animal where the beasts patience
and love transforms him into whatever
the hell that is Gaston is funny while
also being threatening which in some
ways makes him a much more
three-dimensional character he's not
evil just to be evil he's just always
used to getting what he wants and as a
result will continue to do anything to
get even evil horrible things funny
tough and always getting his way Gaston
was somehow the essence of both
prettiness and manliness at the same
time
Frollo from the Hunchback of Notre Dom
where do I begin with this guy he kills
an innocent woman tries to drive her
baby keeps him in a bell tower burns
people alive lusts over women offers
their freedom for sex and all while
claiming he's a good Christian sounds
like a 19th century Bill O'Reilly to me
haha oh come on everybody's made a Bill
O'Reilly joke I had to get one Frollo
was a sinister creature playing a
religious judge who longs to purge the
world of sin he gets away with doing
horrible terrible things because he
reasons with the people and himself
that's what God ultimately wants him to
do what a dick he also has one of the
best and creepiest song sequences ever
put in the Disney film where he
confesses his lust for Esmeralda and
that if he can't have her the pits of
hell will
you know for kids actually Frollo did
make this movie a lot more adult than
most children are used to and we just
loved it for that he was born with no
soul no heart and no regrets from
working on the dark side of the cross
lady tremaine aka the evil stepmother
from Cinderella I could punch this lady
in the face I hated her so much she
didn't have any weapons fighting moves
or even evil minions
she just had control over one person's
life and boy did she squeeze every last
drop out of it
she made poison to really do everything
clean the house feed the animals
everything why all because she didn't
push Cinderella out of her couch that's
the only reason she gives her real
daughters everything and Cinderella
nothing but a load of bitch look at the
way she sits on that bed stroking but
kid she's like a Bond villain and how
about that smile
gosh she's just dripping with horror so
okay making a woman do chores isn't all
that bad but no she goes even further
she prevents Cinderella from going to
the ball because he gives her too much
work to do
has her daughters ripped apart her dress
because it's brought from old unused
clothes and even locks her in her room
destroying her chance for a happy life
that's just waiting for her downstairs
you spidery brought Oh chilly
nah no hard feelings huh no please don't
give me that stare it's a scary stare in
cinema history no please
evil despicable and loving every minute
of it Lady Tremaine what a bitch
Maleficent from Sleeping Beauty voiced
by the exact same actress Maleficent had
the same wickedness and sophisticated
evil that lady tremaine paired the only
difference she could whoop your ass in a
second maleficents motivation is pretty
simple horribly kill and murder the
daughter of a king because she didn't
get invited to a birthday party boy talk
about someone who hates to be snubbed
though a very basic goal Maleficent made
this harmless snub look like an act of
war and treated it just the same
with her magical powers elegant Grace
and diabolical nature a love is endless
colas her heart she's so scary that even
the nostalgic placed her is the greatest
villainous from nostalgic past here's an
idea
stop insulting the rulers of darkness
that'll get you ahead in life like I
said before what made her even better
than someone like Lady Tremaine is that
she actually did have power combining
both the elegant quiet sophisticated
evil with the loud monstrous terrifying
so she can attack you both mentally and
physically a dangerous combination what
else can you say there has never been a
single double or triple threat like this
mistress all illegal
so know what you're thinking those are
some pretty big-name
baddies what the hell else could they
get to top all that well the answer
might actually surprise you so let's not
wait any longer the number one grave
it's Disney animated film villain is the
devil from Fantasia now I know what
you're thinking he didn't do anything he
didn't hatch any diabolical plans and
ruin anybody's life but here's the thing
it's the devil he is evil incarnate
you look at this guy and tell me that
not one of these characters is not
working for wit or was inspired by this
guy he doesn't talk doesn't sing and
doesn't even mess around with any of the
good guys but that's how the devil works
he doesn't strike people down like
maleficent or scheme evil plots like
Frollo he's working through them
motivating them and encouraging every
ounce of evil that they do he doesn't
even need an introduction you just see
him and you can feel evil how can you
not be intimidated when those evil eyes
I love in the music films the devil is
often perceived as something that you
can't see well if you could this is what
he would look like and this is what he
would do playing God with the dead
bringing spirits back to life just so he
can destroy them again he turns Beauty
in the filth moonlight in the fire and
cries for help into consumption and
greed ultimately though the devil can't
compete with the heavenly light that
comes in at the end and leads to what is
probably Disney's most powerful and
beautiful moment ever put green this
portion of Fantasia was daring and
controversial even spawning one of the
first Disney nipples ever to be seen oh
my god women have nipples my childhood
is ruined there's no doubt about it the
devil encompassed everything he was
everything dark everything hateful
everything cool and everything lusting
for power he was the master of all
darkness and portrayed just as that
seeing absolutely no element of good and
all around perfect portrayal of the
devil the number one greatest disney
animated
and that's all there is to report from
the happiest place on earth evil family
members psychotic killers and of course
the principle of Darkness himself see I
hope you enjoyed this list and remember
when you wish upon a star whoa Fargo I'm
the Nostalgia Critic I remember it so
you don't
this is like you see
you
okay I'm recording this because I know
live your leg oh whoa what's up with the
nostalgia critic videos they always take
so long their way so delayed you're lazy
no that's not it at all it's just I have
the strangest most creative computer
problems that make no sense it on this
one is so fascinating I decided to
record it literally it's just playing
Ghostbusters the movie not it's not even
the movie it's just the audio of the
entire movie but look please
nothing is this is like the the the
spyware the adware thing it's doing a
scam right now but nothing else is open
as just playing the audio from from
Ghostbusters Y and of course now it's
not because I just turned the camera on
it wants to make me look stupid but I I
swear that's what's going on it's like
this computer is possessed you have no
idea how weird it is to be editing and
all of a sudden you just hear the music
from Ghostbusters that creepy you hear
hear all right see that's the audio you
hear that here I gotta say excuse me but
this is the Ghostbusters isn't it wait
for it
it goes yes this guy help you you see
you see I don't know what's going on
this computer is possessed and everyone
I talked to has said that they've never
seen someone so many strange computer
problems but I do I am freakin possessed
I don't know why this happens I don't
know how computers work and this isn't
helping
so just anyone that's wondering like oh
you're lazy so I'm not I'm just
possessed I'm not lazy I'm possessed I
just want to get that out there but